اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
انقاذنا جينا قضوا اكثر من 200 ساعه تحت
الانقاض والمتضررون امام فصل قاس من
التشرد والنزوح
محتلون يستغلون كارثه الزلزال لجمع اموال
المتبرعين وابرز اساليبهم المحافظ الرقميه
ومحافظ العملات المشفره
على وقع معارك عنيفه شرقا الجيش الاوكراني
يقر بتقدم الروس في دنيتك ويؤكد انه لن
يتخلى عن بخموت
يعلن تعيين مدير جديد لتويتر بحلول نهايه
العام ويحذر من خطوره الذكاء الاصطناعي
صباح الخير نبدا مشاهدينا بفسحه امل بين
كل هذا الركام فرغم مرور تسعه ايام على
الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا ورغم ما
قيل عن تلاشي فرص العثور على ناجين تكاد
لا تمر ساعات قليله حتى ياتي نبا سار من
هناك بعثوري فرق الانقاذ على ناجين اربعه
نجوا بعد قضاء اكثر من 200 ساعه تحت
الالقاب بينهم انقاذ امراه عمرها 42 عاما
في كهرمان مرعش التركيه بين
222 ساعه او بعد 220 ساعه من الزلزال طبعا
هذا حدث قبل قليل قبل دقائق قليله تم
العثور على هذه السيده وانقاذها سبقها
انقاذ زوجين من تحت مسكنهم المدمر فيها
طائر التركيه وزير الداخليه التركيه قبل
قليل قال ما زال هناك احياء يتم اخراجهم
من تحت الانقاض وهذا يزيد املنا باخراج
المزيد
[موسيقى]
بعد دخول اول قافله مساعدات امميه
مشاهدينا الى شمال سوريا عبر معبر باب
السلامه الحدودي وصلت ثاني طائرات الاغاثه
السعوديه الى مطار حلب السوري والتي تحمل
على متنها مساعدات عاجله لضحايا الزلزال
منها مواد غذائيه وايوائيه وطبيبيه متنوعه
الطائره الاغاثيه السعوديه التي اعلنها
عنها مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه جاءت ضمن سلسله من الطائرات
لمساعده المتضررين في سوريا وتركيا بشكل
عاجل
الطائره الثانيه المتجهه الى مطار حلب
والمغادره من مطار الملك خالد الدولي في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض وهي تعتبر
الطائره التاسعه ضمن الجسر الجوي السعودي
لدعم المتضررين جراء هذا الزلزال اما الان
ننتقل ونواكب ايضا الطائره العاشره ولكن
التي سوف تتجه الى مطار عنتاب داخل
الاراضي التركيه وتحمل على متنها قرابه
التسعينات طن من المواد الغذائيه وكذلك
الخيام
والسلال الغذائيه طبعا الطائره مختلفه وهي
من طراز بوينج 777 سوف تحمل كما ذكرت
الاحتياجات التي رفعها ممثلي مركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه من خلال
السلال الغذائيه والخيام وكذلك ايضا بعض
المحاليل
وكذلك ايضا بعض المستلزمات الطبيه ولكن
لعل هذه الشحنه تحديدا وهي الشحنه العاشره
التي سوف تغادر الى داخل الاراضي التركيه
سوف تكون محمله بشكل اكبر واكثر من
المستلزمات الايوائيه وكذلك السلال
الغذائيه وهي من ضمن الاحتياجات التي
رفعها ممثلي مركز مركز الملك سلمان لغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه خاصه الان بعد انقاذ
العديد من من المدنيين جراء هذا الزلزال
هم الان بلا ماوى وهم يحتاجون الى الغذاء
يحتاجون الى الخيام يحتاجون ايضا الى
الحقائب
المكمله بالاواني الخاصه بهم ايضا سوف
تكون سوف ترافق هذه الشحنه عدد من مقرات
الماوى الذي يتم بشكل سريع وبشكل سهل حتى
يتم اخذ اكبر مساحه واكبر عدد ممكن من
المتضررين الذين تم انقاذهم سواء عبر
الجهات الحكوميه التركيه وكذلك بمساعده
فرق البحث والانقاذ السعودي الذي غادر
الاسبوع الماضي عبر وسائل ويحمل او كان
برفقته اليات وتقنيات تساعد في عمليات
البحث والانقاذ وكذلك وسائل حيه تساعد
ايضا على الكشف على من هم تحت الركام
ينضم الينا من معبر التائهه شمال سوريا
مراسل العربيه جمعه عكاش اهلا بك معنا
جمعه اذا مع ازدياد وتيرات وصول المساعدات
الى مختلف المعابر الجمعه هل لك ان تحصر
لنا حجم هذه المساعدات
جمعه هل تسمعني
المساعدات الدوليه والامميه وحتى الان الى
عموم مناطق السيطره في سوريا 4
شاحنه
تركزت بشكل اساسي عبر
باب الذي شاحنه حتى الان اضافه
الاكراد دخلت الى مناطق عبر معبراير
يبدو ان الصوت يتقطع كثيرا بسبب الاتصال
وضعف الاتصال في المنطقه التي تتواجد بها
سنعود اليك حال تمكنا الجمعه
[موسيقى]
الى تركيا حيث افاد مشاهدينا مراسل
العربيه بانتهاء عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
حي نورداغ في غازي عنتاب كما ان اداره
الهجره دعت لمغادره منطقتي نورداغ
واصلاحيه اللتين امتلاتا بالمخيمات وكشفت
ايضا مصادر خاصه للعربيه ان الدعوه لاخلاء
المنطقتين جاءت بسبب الدمار الضخم جراء
الزلزال وافادت مصادرنا ايضا بان السلطات
التركيه تعتزم هدم منطقتين نورداغ
واصلاحيه بشكل كامل وهدم 200 الف وحده
سكنيه بحاجه الى هدم عاجل في هذا الزلزال
شرد وعشرات الالاف اكثرهم يفترسون الارض
في ظروف جويه بارده واوضاع قاسيه فضل
الضغط الكبير على مراكز الايواء ونقص
الخيم اما بالنسبه للسوريين فالامر ابعد
من مجرد كارثه هي قصه لجوء طويله الامد
ومتعدده الفصول
نوبه الهزه الارضيه في سوريا وتركيا هزت
معها قلوب اللاجئين يفرون من ملجا الى اخر
عبروا الحدود ليكابد قسوه الحرب
وقسوه كارثه طعم الفقد والبرد
والنزوح من جديد
هناك عدد كبير من الاشخاص الذين ليس لديهم
منازل لقد واجهوا 12 عاما من الازمه والان
حل الدمار عليهم مجددا مجلس مدينه حلب قال
ان اكثر من 150 الف شخص غادروا منازلهم في
محافظه حلب ونحو 13 الف عائله تتوزع في
235 مركز ايواء والله يعني المصاب جلال
شوفه عينك
فيما اكدت منظمه منسق استجابه سوريا انهم
يواجهون عجزا هائلا في عمليه الاستجابه
الانسانيه وان مراكز الايواء غير كافيه
لاستيعاب النازحين وتامين احتياجاتهم
مجردون بين جوانح طقس
وشح في المساعدات وصل عددهم الى اكثر من
780,000 كحصيله غير نهائيه
في ظل تحديات ايواء المتضررين تحولت
القطارات في مدينه اوسمان التركيه الى
ماوى للنازحين
[موسيقى]
معنى من عمان المتحدث باسم اليونيسف في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا محمد الحواري
اهلا بك معنا سيد محمد الكوارث في سوريا
تتداخل يعني هذه كارثه تواجهها تركيا
وسوريا ولكن نتحدث قليلا وبدايه عن سوريا
فالكوارث هناك تتداخل يعني الذين هربوا
ونزحوا من الحرب يواجهون الان
التشرد والضرر من هذا الزلزال كيف سيتم
التعامل معهم اين سيتم ايواءهم خصوصا انهم
تركوا بلادهم لينجحوا الى تركيا
والانواجهوا هذا الزلزال واضرار هذا
الزلزال
هو انت ذكرتي سابقا معلومه جدا مهمه ان
هذا الشعب او هذه المنطقه الناس الذي
يسكنون فيها تعرضوا للنزوح اكثر من مره
تعرضوا الى النزوح واللجوء ما يقارب الخمس
مرات في عقد من الزمان يعني عندما تصنف
هذه الازمه الحاليه هذا الزلزال بانه
الاسوا منذ مئه عام هو حقيقه كذلك لان هم
المنازل الذين كانوا فيها او نسميها اماكن
الايواء التي كانوا يتواجدون فيها اثناء
الزلزال هي ليست بوطنهم الدائم وليست هي
بمسكنهم الدائم وللاسف حدث ما حدث وتدمره
لذلك اليوم نحن نولئ اهميه كبرى الى اصلاح
المراكز اللواء المركزيه بمحاوله ايصال
المياه الصالحه للشرب كمسؤوليه علينا نحن
كيونيسف والتاكد من سلامه المنطقه من عدم
انتشار اي نوع من انواع الاوبئه والحفاظ
على المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه لهم اما اين
سيسكنون الاعدادات الدوليه والمشاركه
الموجوده من جميع دول العالم هي في
الحقيقه
تدفئ القلب قليلا بالرغم من حجم الماساه
الا ان هناك اصبح في بدائل مؤقته حتى يتم
ايجاد حلول مركزيه يعني اذا تحدثنا عن
المباني المركزيه في داخل مدن او المراكز
المجتمعيه نسبه الدمار فيها طال اكثر من
500 مدرسه على سبيل المثال اول مركز
المجتمعيه التي هم شركائنا يوجد من بعض
المراكزها ما تتضرر نحن نعمل على الارض
مباشره مع اكثر من 17 شريك مباشر هم
يقومون بايصال المساعدات للمحتاجين مباشره
مع التقييم الاخير بقرابه السبعه مليون
طفل ما بين تركيا وسوريا في الداخل السوري
ما يزيد على مليونين و400 لكن هو ليس فقط
الاطفال المتضررين بل ايضا اهاليهم الذين
هم يرعوهم لذلك يجب مراعاه ودعم جميع س
العائله نعم طيب السيد محمد يعني هؤلاء
المتضررين والمشردين اثر هذا الزلزال من
غير الجنسيه التركيه وانا اتحدث عن
السوريين ما ان لم يحدث اي حل سريع لهم
ولتواجدهم في تركيا هناك ان تتحدث عن ربما
اعادتهم الى سوريا يعني في سوريا ليس لديه
لديهم منزل او ايواء او شيء يعودون له حتى
الان
نحن كمنظمه عمل انساني بكل تاكيد ناصر كل
قرار من شانه تحسين اوضاعهم وليس عودتهم
الى مكانهم فروا به من الاصل وكما تفضلت
انه البنيه التحتيه قد لا تكون بل هي غير
موجوده
لاستضافتهم او عودتهم اليها لذلك يجب
ايجاد حل ومشاركه دوليه من دول العالم
لذلك لكن هناك منظمات متخصصه مثل منظمه
المفوضيه الساميه لشؤون اللاجئين وايضا
منظمه الهجره الدوليه هي من تقوم بمناسبه
ومسانده هذا القرار ونحن حريصون جدا بان
لا يتم المساس وحقوق الاطفال تحديدا في
هذه المرحله وخصوصا منطقه
الدوليه والمجتمع الدولي خذلوا الشعب
السوري في عده مرات وخدلوهم ايضا في هذا
الزلزال وهذه الكارثه بعدم ارسال
المساعدات والمعدات التي يطالبون بها منذ
اليوم الاول من الكارثه
اتفهم حقيقه
هذا هذا المطلب
ونحن مثلكم يعني ننظر اليه بمنظور انه يجب
ان يتم المساعده والمستجابه فورا لكن يجب
ان نوجه كل
مسائله لكل جهه مسؤوله عنها نحن كمنظمه
يونس كمنظمه عمل انساني متخصصه في عمل
الطفوله كنا متواجدين من يوم من اليوم
الاول بل كان لدينا مستودعات فيها من
المواد الغذائيه والاغاثيه ما قدمناه
جميعه صحيح انه غير كافي لان الاحتياج كان
اضخم بكثير مما مما هو متوفر لكن قدمنا كل
ما لدينا بل سحبنا كل ما موجوداتنا في
المستودعات الاخرى الدوليه الخاصه بحالات
الطوارئ وقدمناها بل استطعنا توفير فريق
خدمه نفسيه مباشره على الارض من ثاني يوم
من هذا المصاب لكن القرارات السياسيه التي
تسالين عنها هي يجب ان توجه مباشره لاصحاب
السياسه لماذا هذا الصراع ما زال وجودا
هذا السؤال من الاصل هؤلاء الاطفال
اجابه له حتى الان شكرا لك من عمان
المتحدث باسم اليونيسف في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا محمد الحواري
ان جونا من الزلزال في تركيا وفي سوريا
معرضون لتهديد خطر النفسي بعيد المدى
ومتعدد الاعراض وهو ما يستوجب التدخل
العاجل صدمات ما بعد الزلزال نتابعها
ثم بعد الزلزال
ان دون معرضون لاضطراب شده الصدمه الحاده
خمسه الى عشره في المئه ممن تعرضوا لزلزال
يصابون بهذا الاضطراب اعراضه التوتر
والخوف والرعب الذكريات المؤلمه ايضا
والاكتئاب
التدخل النفسي سريع يخفف الاعراض لكن
استمرار صدمه يسبب امراضا عضويه ابرزها
ارتفاع ضغط الدم السكري وجلطات القلب
الناجون بحاجه الى دعم نفسي عاجل
[موسيقى]
مستمرين معكم ولكن بعد الفاصل ونتابع في
الزلزال ضحايا رحلوا تحت الانقاض واطفت
ذكرياتهم فوق الركام
احييكم من جديد مشاهدينا في الزلزال
والكارثه التي وقعت في سوريا وتركيا ابشع
سيناريوهات الزلزال ليس الكارثه فحسب بل
ما حذر منه خبراء امنيون حول من يستغلون
هذه الزلازل في تركيا وسوريا لمحاوله خداع
من يرغبون في التبرع للضحايا حيث تحققوا
من بعض الطرق التي يستخدمها المحتالون على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ليستعطفوا
المتابعين ثم يحولون الاموال لحساباتهم
الشخصيه على تطبيق المحافظ الرقميه
المعروف
والمحافظ المشفره بدلا من المؤسسات
الخيريه الحقيقيه اذ يمكن لصانع المحتوى
على بث تيك توك على سبيل المثال ان يجني
الاموال من خلال تلقي الهدايا الرقميه بعد
ابراز صوره او لقطات متكرره للدمار وجهود
الانقاذ من تركيا وسوريا ثم طلب التبرعات
فبعض المحتالين لجاوا لاستخدام عبارات مثل
فلنساعد تركيا
لنصلي من اجل تركيا
وتبرعوا لضحايا الزلزال ويرفقونها بصور
اعدوها على برامج الذكاء الاصطناعي
كما ان الخبراء الامنيين اكدوا ان احدى
الصور المستخدمه في جلب التبرعات لم تكن
صور ملتقطه خلال الزلزال وانما نشرت على
موقع تويتر في عام 2018 مرفقه بجمله
توضيحيه تقول اوقفوا الاباده الجماعيه في
عفرين من دبي ينضم الينا انس المرعي
المتخصص في الشؤون المعلوماتيه والتقنيه
اهلا بك معنا سيد انس اذا طرق ووسائل عده
للاحتيال ونهب اموال التبرعات ما هي ابرز
هذه الطرق والوسائل التي رستموها سيد انس
اهلا بك فاطمه وبجميع المشاهدين اسمحي لي
بدايه اترحم على ارواح جميع المفقودين في
زلزال سوريا وتركيا بصراحه طرق الاحتيال
لا منتهي هناك الكثير والكثير والالاف من
طرق الاحتيال خلينا نركز على الشيء اللي
حضرتك
ذكرتيه في المقدمه
وخصوصا تيك توك هي واحده من اكثر المنصات
للسرقه اللي عم بتصير في حمله التبرعات
خلينا نعرض اكثر من جانب لحتى
خلينا نوعي الناس في في طرق هالاحتيال
وكيف
نتجنبه اول شيء
شكرا اول شيء البيتكوين يعني انا خلينا
نقول وعي المتبرع هو اهم شيء اهم شيء في
هاي العمليه انا كشخص اليوم بدي احط يعني
بدي افكر بيه للناس اللي
ناس منكوبه اكيد خصوصا في سوريا خلينا
نقول هم ابعد ما يمكن عن عالم البيتكوين
والعملات المشفره بشكل عام وبالتالي اي
شخص يطلب مني انه اتبرع بالعملات المشفره
هذا فورا بحطوه في القائمه السوداء
بالنسبه للتيك توك وغيره من منصات
السوشيال ميديا الوعي الوعي المطلوب يعني
ليش انا اتبرع على شخص يستجدين على تيك
توك ليش ما انظر للدوله اللي انا مقيم
فيها وبالتالي اتبرع للجهات الرسميه في
هاي الدوله فمثلا نحن في دول الخليج
العربي موضوع التبرع مقنن بشكل مضبوط شبه
يكون يعني
مثالي مئه بالمئه التبرع له قوانين وهناك
جمعيات معروفه في كل دوله فمثلا على سبيل
المثال الهلال الاحمر السعودي الاماراتي
الكويتي البحريني القطري
المتخصصه ومختصه في جمع التبرعات السيد
انس يعني انت تركز كثيرا على وعي المتبرع
ولكن
نعم الجهه المفترض انها امنه ورسميه
ومعتمده فكيف نفرق بين المواقع الرسميه
والمواقع المزوره
تمام النقطه الاولى هي خلينا نروح بنقطتين
بعجال النقطه الاولى اللي هي المواقع
الالكترونيه والنقطه الثانيه اللي هي
السوشيال ميديا خلينا نبدا بالمواقع
الالكترونيه الموقع الالكتروني هنالك موقع
عالمي مجاني من جمعيه الانترنت العالميه
اسمه اركان
في موقع بضعه داخل اركايف دوت اورج
بيعطيني تاريخ انشاء الموقع الالكتروني
والتعديلات التي طرات على كل صفحه وكل قسم
في هذا الموقع وبالتالي اذا الموقع انشئ
خلال اسبوعين
راح اضع عليه علامه استفهام كبيره بانه
هذا موقع غير قانوني خلينا نقول الموقع
لازم يكون دوت اورج على الاغلب نعم الهلال
الاحمر الاماراتي مثلا
اي اي لا ينتهي بدوت اوغو ولكنه جهه رسميه
معروفه ومعتمده من الدوله فالاغلب لكن
هناك بعض المواقع القليله فمثلا على سبيل
المثال ايضا
هو واحد من
المواقع الموثوق فيها هذا بالنسبه
للمواقع نروح على السوشيال ميديا السوشيال
ميديا اليوم فيسبوك وانستجرام انشات او
ميته انشات شيء اسمه مركز الشفافيه او قسم
الشفافيه اليوم اذا بتدخلي على اي صفحه في
انستجرام او فيسبوك هنالك قسم بيكون تحت
في الصفحه على اليسار عم بحكي عن صفحه
يعني صفحه رسميه
وليس بروفايل شخصي وليس حساب شخص الحساب
شخصي هذا يعني خلينا نقول مفروغ منه
الحسابات الشخصيه نهائيا والابلاغ عنها
كذلك سيد انس نعم نعم نرجع للحسابات
الصفحات في قسم فيها تحت بالانجليزي بيكون
مكتوب
قسم الشفافيه في هذا القسم فاطمه بيعطينا
تاريخ انشاء الصفحه والتغييرات التي طرات
على اسم هذه الصفحه وبالتالي انا عندي
القدره على معرفه اذا كانت هذه الصفحه
جديده هنالك علامه استفهام كبيره وممكن
يكونوا محتالين لكن اذا الصفحه كانت قديمه
والاسم ما تغير او كانت تغيير يعني مثلا
منظمه خلينا نقول منظمه الناجين اوكي
منظمه الناجين العالمي يعني ما صار اختلاف
كان سوبر ماركت او كان باسم شركه او كان
باسم غريب وتحول لمؤسسه خيريه خلال خلال
فتره سريعه هذا وحده من اهم الاشياء طيب
كيف نعمل كل هذه السبل توضح ان بالفعل
المسؤوليه تقع على عاتق المستخدم او
المتبرع طيب هل من طريقه لربما يعني تتبع
هذه التتبع المحتالين تتبع المواقع التي
تكون مزوره
مهم جدا
المواقع المعتمده داخل كل دوله في
المحتالين احيانا بالايميل او الموقع
بيكون في اضافات على الموقع فمثلا الهلال
الاحمر
الدولي بروحوا بيكتبوا كلمه جديده في
الموقع هنالك اضافات في الموقع لكن ما في
ما في يعني طريقه
سهله جدا لكشف هذا المحتال لازم كل النقاط
اللي اللي ذكرناها لازم نمشي فيها نقطه
نقطه ممكن ينكشف معنى المحتال من اول نقطه
من مركز الشفافيه او من
انه هذا الموقع الجديد كثير طريقه التبرع
ايضا يعني هون بيعطي ممكن يشارك نقطه ممكن
ان اتبرع بدولار يعني مؤسسه انا حاسس انها
مئه بالمئه او تسعه وتسعين بالمئه حاسس
بانها
مؤسسه حقيقيه بتبرع بريان بدرهم بدينار
بدولار واحد بيجيني رساله نصيه رساله نصيه
بيكون عاطيني اسم الشركه اللي انا تبرعت
لها قانونيا هون انا بكتشف وين هاي
المؤسسه واسمها الرسمي بالنسبه نرجع
للموضوع الاول اللي طرحه
من الجدد بقبض فلوسهم بعد 21 يوم عمل
ويسمح للمؤسسات اللي اللي موجوده
اوتوماتيك يعني الموجوده عنده منذ زمن
بثلاث الى خمس ايام فاذا تبرعتم بمبلغ
واكتشفته انه هذا المبلغ اللي تبرعته فيه
لمؤسسه طلعت محتاله فيكم تتواصلوا مع باي
بال وخلال ثلاث الى خمس ايام
ايضا السيد انس انا لا يستخدم ولا يعمل في
تركيا منذ 2016 وهذه نقطه مهمه للانتباه
لها شكرا لك من دبي انس المرعي المتخصص في
الشؤون المعلوماتيه والتقنيه
مشاهدينا تحاول تركيا وجاراتها او جارتها
سوريا العوده الى الحياه الطبيعيه بعد
الزلزال الذي ترك اجزاء كبيره من مدنها في
حاله نكبه لكن يبدو ان الدولتين قد
تواجهان كارثه اخرى تتجاوز اضرارها خسائر
الزلزال وتتمثل في ازمه صحيه كبرى حذرت
منها منظمه الصحه العالميه خاصه وان عدد
المتضررين قد يتجاوز 23 مليون شخص بينهم
خمسه ملايين في وضع هش لان المخيمات تعاني
من نقص المواد الاساسيه والمواد الطبيه
وتعاني ايضا من نقص مستحضرات الوقايه من
الميكروبات وتنتشر فيها المخلفات ففي
سوريا ظهر وباء الكوليرا مجددا وبينما
تحاول تركيا وسوريا التقاط انفاسهما برزت
قضيه المفقودين والسؤال ذاته يتردد في
اذهان الناجين اين بقيه عائلتنا
في سياره المسكره
في حدا اكل ولادي
معنا
توالي الايام بعد الزلزال تطفو على سطح
الركام قصص وذكريات لمن قضوا تحتها صور
واغراض وثقت حياتهم وتحولت الى ذكرى
للناجين من الكارثه مفيد العربيه يرصد
المشهد في قهرمان مرعش
توقفت العاصفه في هذا الموقع في كهرمانشاه
ذهب رجال الانقاذ ورجال الاسعاف
والمتسمرين لايام طويله في هذا الموقع الا
ان شيئا بقي على هذا الكرسي ذكريات ولحظات
سعيده ليسرق مكونه من سته اشخاص قضت في
هذا الموقع لم ينجوا منهم احد ولكن
ذكرياتهم بقت للماره الذين يسلكون هذا
الطريق يتسمرون امام الصور امام الذكريات
وامام لحظات وثقوها بانفسهم وضعت في هذا
الموقع جميعها استخرجت الا هم خرجوا الى
المقابر الجماعيه اشاهد بعض الصور التي
تداولوها فيما بينهم يبدو ان هذه الاسره
كانت تعمل في التجاره حتى كتب احدهم لاحد
اخر اللهم احفظ هذه التجاره المركزيه لكن
تجارتهم انتهت وبقيت ذكرياتهم في هذا
الموقع في كهرمان مرعش عبد المحسن الحربي
لقناته العربيه والحدث كهرمان مرش
دينا كيف ان فرق الانقاذ تمكنت قبل قليل
من انقاذ امراه تبلغ من العمر 42 عاما في
كهرمان مرعش امضت 222 ساعه تحت الانقاض
وفي ظل انقاذ نحو خمسه اشخاص بعد مرور
اكثر من 200 ساعه تحت الانقاض قال وزير
الداخليه التركي ما زال هناك احياء يتم
اخراجهم من تحت الانقاض وهذا يزيد الامل
باخراج المزيد معنى من منطقه اصلاحيه في
غازي عنتاب زيدان زنكلو مراسل العربيه
اهلا بك معنا زيدان في ظل تصريحاء في ظل
هذه التصريحات وفي ظل المزيد من الامال
بوجود المزيد من الاحياء انقل لنا الصوره
لديك
نعم فاطمه نحن نتواجد في احد المخيمات في
مدينه اصلاحيه هذه المدينه المنكوبه بكل
ما لهذه الكلمه من معنى في كل خيمه هنا في
هناك قصه وهناك حكايه هناك شهادات عن
الزلزال وهناك مفقودين
لم يعد لم يعدوا موجودين مع عائلاتهم انا
في هذه المنطقه قبل قليل وصلت والتقيت بام
احمد وهي لاجئه السوريه كانت تقيم في
اصلاحيتها هدم منزلها تهدم منزلها وفقدت
ثلاثه من ابنائها مع الاسف واحاول الان
ساحاول ان التقي بها واجري مع هذه
المقابله لنستمع الى شهادتها وما جرى معهم
اثناء الزلزال اول شيء ام احمد البقيه
بحياتكم انا حاب تحكي لي وقت اللي صار
الزلزال انت وين كنتي وشو اللي صار معكم
انا كنت كان وقتها بردو ثلج كنت عم بكب
صوت له صوبه
انا وجارتي الله يرحمه
بعدين ما احسنت اطلع هون انطبق الباب باب
الدار قام بعدين ما في خلال دقيقه مشط
للبنايه
الاربعه وهذا معه
عمرها اربع سنين تصيح يا ماما ما حدا يحسن
طالع
ومين هن اولادك اللي ماتوا بنتين وصبي
بنتين وصبي البنت عمرها 17 سنه وبنت عمرها
اربع سنين والصبي عمره 12 سنه طب ما كان
في فرق انقاذ تيجي تساعدكم او تحاول تطلع
اولادك من تحت الانقار الوقت قطعت
الكهرباء والدنيا ثلج والشاطر ملتهي
بعيلته ما اجوا لبعد يومين
كانت بنتي خالصه البنت الصغيره فطست فطست
جرح ما فيها بس هادوكي قلبت الجسر على
ظهرهم
وعراسه الصبي خلص مع الحارق ماتوا وقتها
الله يرحمهم جميعا ويصبركم خبرتيني
ودفنتوهم بسوريا
الله الله يجزيه الخير يا رب عامر عامر
اليونس كتير ساعدني وقف معي من الاول لاخر
لحظه هلا راح سافر عند عيلته الله ييسر له
زوجك اللي موجود قلتي لي زوجك كان موجود
بسوريا قبل الزلزال مو هيك جوزي راح على
سوريا قبل الزلزال بسبعه ايام راح بده
يعزي امه ماتت اخته عمرها 22 سنه اجتها
سكتي قلبيه قام بعدين الحمد لله رب
العالمين اجا شغلة ولاده راح ابر ولاده
وانا وصلت لهم لباب الهواء انا وعامر
اليونس
وصلنا الى باب الهواء اخذوه من اخذوهم مني
اهلي واهله
ابروهن هونيك انا ما رضيت تقبرون هوني ما
بعرف هيك
زوجك هلا وين ما بعرف هو بادلب قالولي انه
سوى حادث بس ما بعرف شيء عنه بعد ما دفن
بعد ما دفن الاولاد ما حدا خبرني شيء عنه
يعطيني الخيمه عم ننتظر فرج الله
الله يخلي لك اياه ويا رب يعني يكون سند
لالك وسند لزوجك ان شاء الله يا رب تلتقوا
عن جديد وان شاء الله يعني مثل ما بيقولوا
يعني ما في كلمات توصف الماسه ان شاء الله
يا رب اخر المصايب ويكون ابنك هو قره عين
لالك ويكون سند لالك وان شاء الله قريبا
تلتقي مع زوجك ان شاء الله شكرا كثير لالك
كنت معنا على قناه العربيه شكرا لحضرتك
كثير نعم فاطمه كما تابعتي وكما سمعتي هذه
القصه الحزينه جدا
هنا في احدى الخيام في مدينه اصلاحيها هي
احدى من مئات او قصه من مئات القصص
الماساويه التي خلفها هذا الزلزال المدمر
هنا في اصلاحيه وفي
غازي عنتاب وفي تسع ولايات اخرى ضربها هذا
زلزال فاطمه نعم شكرا لك من منطقه اصلاحيه
في غازي عنتاب زيدان زين كلو شكرا لضيوفك
الكرام
رحم الله موتاهم وكان الله في عونهم
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع فيها
المنطاد الصيني للتجسس امنحرفه عن مساره
بسبب الطقس واشنطن تغير الاحتمالات
انقاذنا جينا قضوا اكثر من 200 ساعه تحت
الانقاض والمتضررون امام فصل قاس من
التشرد والنزوح
محتالون يستغلون كارثه الزلزال لجمع اموال
المتبرعين وابرز اساليبهم المحافظ الرقميه
ومحافظ العملات المشفره
على وقع معارك عنيفه شرقا الجيش الاوكراني
يقر بتقدم الروس في دنيه كويؤكد انه لن
يتخلى عن بخموت
يعلن تعيين مدير جديد لتويتر بحلول نهايه
العام ويحذر من خطوره الذكاء الاصطناعي
حياكم الله من جديد وعلى وقعي معارك
محتدمه شرق اوكرانيا اقرت القوات
الاوكرانيه بتقدم الجيش الروسي في دونيتك
وقال دينيس بوشيلين القائم باعمال الرئاسه
في جمهوريه دنيتك المعترف بها من قبل
روسيا قال ان الجيش الاوكراني لن يتخلى عن
بخموت بسهوله ومن دون قتال مضيفا ان
القتال العنيف يدور في الجزء الجنوبي
الشرقي من مدينه اوغليدار وان هناك نجاحات
وتقدم للجيش الروسي في مقاطعه دونيتك وفي
محور لمان كومبيانس التي شهدت عوده القوات
الروسيه اليها عقب الانسحاب منها في وقت
سابق هذا واعلنت مشاهدينا وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه في بيان نشرته اليوم عن تراجع
القوات العسكريه الاوكرانيه لمسافه ثلاثه
كيلومترات في منطقه لوغانسك الى ان خط
الدفاع الثاني وهو الاكثر تحصيلا
للاوكرانيين لم يستطع صد هجوم العسكريين
الدفاع الروسيه اشارت ايضا الى ان
الاوكرانيين ه من مواقعهم تركين ممتلكات
عسكريه وجثث القتلى بالاضافه الى الالغام
التي غطت بها القوات الاوكرانيه الملتقى
اليا اثناء تراجعها ينضم الينا من دونيت
كراسل العربيه رائد الاخبار اهلا بك معنا
رائد ما اخر تطورات المعارك على الارض
خصوصا وان الجانب الروسي يقر بتراجع
الاوكران ثلاثه كيلومترات
نهاركم طيب فاطمه بالفعل هناك انخفاض
بوتيره القصف الاوكراني على مناطق
المدنيين هنا في مقاطعه حيث اعلن المصدر
المحلي هنا بان اقل من 100 قذيفه وصاروخ
سقطت على مناطق مختلفه من المقاطعه وخلفت
خمسه اصابات دون ضحايا هذه اشارات فاطمه
لتقدم جيش الروسي وسيطرته على محور
المعارك لان القصف عندما يكون عنيف هذا
يعني بان الجيش الاوكراني يتقدم وعندما
تنخفض وتيره اعداد القذائف والصواريخ التي
تسقط عند المدنيين هنا هذا يعني ان الجيش
الروسي بالفعل يتقدم ويتقدم بمحاور عديده
المحور الاهم وهو باخم كالعاده ربما ليست
هناك اي تطورات كبيره لكن هناك سيطره
للجيش الروسي على احدى البلدات كراسني
غرام منذ عده ايام واكمال تطويق بلده
مجاوره لها
كراسنا عفوا
بلده براسك المجاوره لكريسنيغارا واللتان
تقبعان بالمحور الشمالي من مدينه باخموت
يحاول الجيش الروسي او قوات فاجنر تحديدا
اكمال الطوق اي شكل دائره كامله على
القوات الاوكرانيه وذلك بقطع الطرق التي
تمد الجيش الاوكراني بالاسلحه والذخيره من
الناحيه الغربيه طريقين وهما
[موسيقى]
بالفعل تقول القوات الاوكرانيه نفسها وكيف
تقول بان الجيش الاوكراني بالفعل يقصف هذه
الطرق السريعه التي تؤمن الامدادات
الغذائيه والعسكريه والبشريه للجيش
الاوكراني ربما تطول مده يعني السيطره او
الدخول الى مدينه باقمت حسب ما قال مؤسس
يعني مقاتلي فاقنر بان الحرب عموما او
اكمال السيطره على مقاطعه باكملها تحتاج
لاكثر من عام ونصف كما ان يعني السلطات
المحليه هنا تؤكد بان معارك ضاريه تدور في
جنوب المقاطعه اي حول مدينه اوغلادار
المدينه تتحدث
الذخيره اسرع مما يمكن توفيرها له شكرا لك
من دونك مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
الامريكي اعلن عن ابرام عقود تزيد قيمتها
عن نصف مليار دولار لشراء قذائف مدفعيه
لدعم اوكرانيا على ان تتسلم وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه اولى الدفعات اعتبارا من مارس
المقبل جاء ذلك في وقت تتزايد المخاوف
بشان نفاذ مخزونات الاسلحه والذخيره في
الدول الغربيه بعد استخدام المخزونات
الامريكيه الخاصه في دعم اوكرانيا من
جانبها مشاهدينا قالت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه ان الانتاج الصناعي العسكري
الروسي لا يفي بمتطلبات تزويد العمليه
العسكريه في اوكرانيا بالموارد مشيره الى
انه من المحتمل ان يدرك كبار القاده الروس
ان الانتاج الصناعي العسكري للدوله اصبح
نقطه ضعف خطيره
اعلن ايلون ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه
تويتر انه سيعين شخصا مناسبا لاداره تويتر
بحلول نهايه العام الحالي لتصبح في وضع
مستقر ولها خارطه الطريق واضحه
اعتقد انني بحاجه الى تحقيق الاستقرار في
تويتر والتاكد من ان موقف المنصه الماليه
صحيح ولها خريطه طريق واضحه ربما بحلول
نهايه العام سيكون هناك شخص مناسب يدين
الشركه التي يجب ان تصبح في وضع مستقر هذا
العام
قال ايلون ماسك ايضا مشاهدينا وهو الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه تويتر قال ان الذكاء
الاصطناعي سيكون امرا مقلقا على المدى
القريب خاصه وان العالم لا يولي اهتماما
كبيرا لدرجات امان الذكاء الاصطناعي
والاشراف الرقابي عليه
من الصعب التوقع بشان التطور التكنولوجي
بشكل دقيق خلال عشره اعوام بسبب التطورات
المتسارعه هناك تحول تجاه الطاقه
المستدامه مع طاقه الرياح والبطاريات
والشمس والسيارات الكهربائيه ايضا القاعده
الصناعيه الاقتصادات الوقود الاحفوري
اعتقد ان امكانيه استبدال السيارات
القديمه باخرى تعمل بالطاقه الكهربائيه قد
يستغرق 20 عاما والامر بشكل عام ربما
يحتاج من 30 الى 40 عاما على المدى القريب
الذكاء الاصطناعي سيكون امرا مقلقا خاصه
وان العلم لعيون اهتماما كبيرا بدرجات
امان الذكاء الاصطناعي والاشراف الرقابي
عليه
الى افغانستان الحروب المستمره والاوضاع
الاقتصاديه الصعبه لحقت اضرارا بكل
المؤسسات سواء كانت تعليميه او مهنيه ولم
ترحم حتى المكفوفين ومؤسساتهم التربويه
مراسل العربيه يزور المدرسه الثانويه
المهنيه للمكفوفين في كابول
احمد صميم طالب كفيف في اكبر مدرسه خاصه
للمكفوفين في كابول يجلس في هذا الفصل مع
شقيق له كفيف ايضا يواصلان الدراسه رغم
وفاه والدهم ومعيلهم الوحيد وياملان في
مستقبل افضل
كثيرا من الاطباء والمشافي في الداخل
والجميع قالوا لي اذهب خارج البلاد للعلاج
الى باكستان او اي بلد اخر خالد هو ايضا
من الطلاب المكفوفين يشكوك بقيه زملائه
صعوبه الحياه في مدينه تخلو من اي تسهيلات
خاصه بذوي الاعاقات البصريه يطلب على
الاقل دعما له ولزملائه لمواجهه تحديات
عمليتهم التعليميه نواجه مشاكل في توفير
الكتب الدراسيه وكذلك في الات برايلر التي
لا توجد في المدرسه الا ق ويعترف بذلك
مدير المدرسه والاساتذه
رئاسه التعليم المهني والتقني وهي الجهه
المسؤوله عن المدرسه تعترف بان الانظمه
السابقه لم تقدم اي خدمات تعليميه مناسبه
لذوي الاعاقات البصريه ان شاء الله فعندك
ان شاء الله في المستقبل القريب سوف نقوم
بتامين المعدات والاجهزه التي تحتاجها هذه
المدرسه
طلاب مدرسه المكفوفين يتعلمون مهنا مختلفه
بالاضافه الى تعلم منهج وزاره التعليم
والتربيه عبر اله برايلر على الرغم من ان
المدرسه الثانويه المهنيه للمكفوفين تعتبر
مركزا دافئا لهم فانها لا تزال تواجه
مشاكل كثيره ولم يتم ايلاء الكثير من
الاهتمام لهذه المدرسه حتى من قبل
المؤسسات المسؤوله عبر نادر العربيه كابول
وما تزال قصص الزلزال المدمره التي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا تحكيم الكثير عن المعاناه
الانسانيه لكن بينها قصص تبعث الامل رغم
الالم ففي بلده جنديرس شمال سوريا قام رجل
برمي ابنه الوحيد من نافذه الطابق الرابع
املا في نجاته وفعلا نجا لكن الوالد
وزوجته لم يحظيا بفرصه رؤيه ابنهما مره
اخرى نتابع
يقف على اطلال البيت الذي كان ياويه قبل
ايام
محمود لا يدري ما الذي جرى له متى وكيف
واين هو الان في حضن جده يستمع لقصه ليست
من نزج الخيال بل هي قصه نجاته من هول
الزلزال والله يعني موقف مرعب لدرجه هو
ساكنين طابع الرابع انه هي عم تنهد
البنايه زادته والله اخذه امانته
والحمد لله يعني صابغه خفيفه براسه والحمد
لله واهله الله يرحمهم راحوا
طابق الرابع حكايه نجاه محمود تناقلتها
الالسن وايثار والده حياه ابنه على حياته
حول مجرى الحديث عن الكارثه الى معان
ساميه فخلال ثوان الزلزال المعدوده صب
تفكير الاب على انقاذ ابنه فيما لم يتمكن
هو وزوجته من النجاه
شو بدي اقول لك يعني قالوا لي الطفل بس
انه بخير
انه هاي صبرتني شوي والله لقوه هون هابين
هالبنيات هدول مع انه كله مهبط ولقوه هون
اول بحكي
هيك وجيت في الارض اوقيت ما بيرضى بيحكي
شي
مصدوم يعني تم هذا الحكي بس من يومين لحتى
حكى
سنوات عمره الاربع لم تحجب عنه اهوال ما
عاشه قد لا يعي محمود الان معنى نجاته
وهذا المكان الذي لجات اليه عائلته جراء
الحرب السوريه لم يعد له معنى الان لكن
هذا الركام الذي انهى حياه والديه والالاف
قد يذكر العالم بالمهجرين المنسيين ممن
بقوا على قيد الحياه كحلي محمود عبد
القادر خربوش العربيه
للعناوين
انقاذنا جينا قضوا اكثر من 200 ساعات تحت
الانقاض والمتضررون امام فصل قاس من
التشرد والنزوح
دمتم بخير